If you watch my program with any regularity,
you probably won't be shocked to hear me say
that I'm against violence. I'm against terrorism.
Assume I'm against criminality and vandalism
so I have to call it out no matter who the
perpetrators are. And there's a story that's
gotten relatively little coverage, but it's
extremely disturbing, which is that a self-described
antifascists and anarchists showed up at an
ice facility near Seattle. Washington fire
bombed the place, attempted to bar a burn
cars, buildings. I'll have the details for
you in a second. The man ultimately died after
being shot by police. He actually said that
he was motivated by the recent immigration
raids and deportations that the Trump administration
has been undertaking and the facility in question
had actually had an organized protest earlier
in the day and the fire bomber showed up after
hours very early. The following morning, four
or 5:00 AM through incendiary devices, lit
a car on fire, tried burning down buildings
and approached pain tank and generally wreaked
havoc. We're talking about a 69 year old and
as I mentioned, police ultimately shot him
dead.
Now, the same guy was arrested last year at
a protest outside the same detention center
after allegedly jumping onto a police officer.
We know the man's motivations, uh, because
before he showed up, he wrote a letter to
friends calling it a manifesto saying he was
going to quote, take action against the forces
of evil, specifically fascism and quote, concentration
camps. He wrote, I am Antifa, although later
he also said he's not actually affiliated
with any organization. So listen, w when these
things happen, it's important for progressive
commentators to talk about it. When we don't,
we do two things. Number one, we give the
right ammunition to claim that the left only
covers right wing violence. And to say that
we are hypocrites, we don't want that. We
are not, though the hypocrisy right now is
mostly on the right. And we need to keep it
that way.
If we're against violence, we need to condemn
it in all forms, no matter the political orientation.
Now, just as importantly, it's important to,
uh, talk about these stories because it does
provide another opportunity to mention that
the overwhelming majority of politically motivated
violence in the United States is right wing
period. So I know as, as is often the case,
many people on both sides are going to be
angry with me for this story. There will be
some on the left who are angry that I'm even
talking about this incident. They will say
this was just a mentally ill guy. The fact
that he, he was an antifascist or whatever
against Trump's concentration camps, he's
really just a mentally ill guy, David. You
shouldn't even be talking about it. There
will be people on the right who will be angry
because they'll say, David, this is a story
about left wing violence.
Uh, why are you making this about right wing
violence? Well, listen, left when violence
exists, this particular incident, uh, is also
being described as either a suicide by cop
attempt by people who knew the man. That mental
illness was really the factor here. But it
doesn't matter either way. This is one incident,
at least at the surface level, the radicalization
appears to be left wing radicalization. Okay.
No country of 340 million people. There will
be examples of everything, but the bigger
numbers point in really clear directions and
it's that most of the political violence in
the United States comes from the right when
it comes to Antifa and condemning them. This
show has never been a show that placates or
embraces these types of groups. I have been
completely against movements that use violence,
uh, in order to try to achieve their political
goals. Number one, when it comes specifically
to a group that claims to be antifascist.
When you say you are against fascism, and
this goes now to Antifa, not to this guy who
wasn't even affiliated in any kind of formal
way with these groups, when you claim to be
against fascism and you employ violent authoritarian
tactics to suppress what you see as fascism,
it's implicitly contradictory. Number two,
remember Antifa is tiny. How many people are
we even talking about here? This is not how
positive change will come to the United States.
And I've made that clear and I don't know
that I need to really try to bolster my credentials
of being against violence. Uh, that's been
made pretty clear over the last many, many
years on the program. Number three, this particular
guy considered himself an antifascist but
made clear he's not part of any group. So
this individual was a combination of someone
who, yes, does appear to have significant
emotional disturbance, who has been radicalized
but is also independent and with access to
firearms, which is not something that's been
discussed.
Most of the coverage of this story, which
as I mentioned, the left should be covering
it. I've mostly seen only the right cover
at the right has not even mentioned the firearms
component. If you're going to seriously talk
about what's going on here, talk about the
radicalization against fascism and against
Trump's deportation. Sure. That's a part of
it. Talk about mental illness. That's often
a part, uh, of any incident where people are
motivated to do this stuff. Talk about the
guys affiliation short. Talk about all of
those things. How do you do the story though
without talking about the fact that this guy
had ready easy access to firearms that in
many countries he would not have had access
to. You're not seriously covering the story
unless you also talk about the firearm components.
So we on the left don't have to shy away from
covering these stories.
Anecdotally, people like this are not nearly
the biggest problem that we're dealing with.
I completely denounced this person's actions.
I completely am against any of these violent
actions by anybody under the umbrella of Antifa
or whatever group they claim to be a part
of. No matter what ideological or political
agreements or disagreements I would have with
anyone on the left, right? Middle and arch
is whatever. Uh, these are tactics that I
am against full stop period and the left doesn't
need to shy away from it. And in particular
we don't need to shy away from it because
we are right on the issues. And again, most
of the violence, if you really want to deal
with political violence in the u s you are
[inaudible] disproportionately dealing with
right wingers who are the source of that violence.
Disagree with me. Many of you might. I'm,
uh, open to hearing from you, change my mind
about anything that I've said here. I'm on
Twitter at d pacman. The show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show. We have a tremendous,
tremendous Friday show for you today. Uh,
and we will take a quick break and continue
right after this